we are now two days removed from october
3rd the day of the bathroom insurrection
against senator cinema a day that will
live in infamy it was an assault on our
democracy and our very way of life
it wouldn't be too far to say that it
was the worst attack on our nation ever
like pearl harbor and 911 combined twice
i'll always remember where i was when it
happened
and i fear that i'll i'll never be the
same
i almost died that day
at least this is what would be said
about the incident if it had been
right-wing activists harassing a
lawmaker in the bathroom but left-wing
activists are judged on a different
scale and the measurement on that scale
the measurements are quite simple to
read it goes like this whatever the
left-wing activist does is okay
they must have had a good reason to do
it so when they stalk senator cinema in
a restroom filmed her as she went into
the bathroom stall and yelled at her for
not supporting by the agenda it was
shrugged off by biden himself here is
biden in a press conference yesterday
responding to the incident and not
exactly condemning it listen
mr president you're talking about how
you have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two uh have been pressured over the
weekend by activists joe manchin had
people on kayaks show up to his boat gl
adam senator cinema last night was
chased into a restroom do you think that
those tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people
who have secret service standing around
them um so it's it's part of the process
oh yeah so you know one thing i take
from that is uh hey senator cinema
doesn't have secret service protection
standing around her hind hint
it's all just part of the process
he says it happens to everybody i mean
i would wonder who else has it happened
to really everybody gets filmed in
bathrooms
who else
maybe i shouldn't be surprised that the
creepy perv biden thinks filming women
in restrooms is part of the process
although i'd hate to know what kind of
process he's referring to exactly in
fact the left seems in general to have a
thing for a costing women in restrooms
one minute they're defending a male sex
predator who exposes erect penis to
women and children in the wii spa locker
room and the next they're cheering
illegal alien activists for confronting
a senator while she's on the toilet
these people just really don't think
women should have privacy in the
bathroom at all they just don't they
don't believe that and not just in the
bathroom either she being confronted
cinema over the last few days has been
harassed at her home
in the airport
on a plane
everywhere she goes now they follow and
scream at her because she doesn't fully
agree with biden's spending proposals
the feminist website jezebel published a
piece yesterday
directly calling for more harassment of
the senator in the bathroom in a piece
titled absolutely bully kristen cinema
outside of the bat of her bathroom stall
jezebel writer ashley reese waves off
the criticism of these intimidation
tactics as pearl clutching and says that
it was quote just a few constituents
following their representative into a
large bathroom to air their grievances
oh well as long as the bathroom was
large then never mind
jezebel represents the view of many on
the left including in the media chris
kirsten powers cnn contributor tweeted
on monday referring to one of the
illegal alien harassers who said that
her grandparents had been deported
she said which is worse your
grandparents being deported or being
followed into a bathroom because you
refused to stop and listen by people
desperate for your help this is not a
trick question
oh i can answer that um
being followed into the bathroom and
filmed is worse
okay that's that's illegal behavior
deporting illegal aliens on the other
hand
is law enforcement
so on in one case the law is being
broken
and in the other it's being enforced
so not a trick question and also not a
hard answer
but as we've seen the left views the law
as a rather blurry and subjective line
and they have good reason to see it that
way i mean if they're acting on behalf
of their ideology
they know that they're empowered to do
basically whatever they want they can
film senators in the bathroom they can
show up with bull horns to people's
homes in the middle of the night
they can riot they can loot they can
assault police officers they can burn
police stations to the ground they can
wage a months-long assault on a federal
courthouse they can stop traffic
they can harass and assault random
pedestrians and people and vehicles
they're able to do all of this with
rarely any penalty penalty
and meanwhile in the midst of of all of
it
the fbi has now officially been put on
the case of conservative parents who say
mean things to school board members
attorney general merrick garland on
monday while left-wing activists and
illegal aliens were stalking a u.s
senator across the country
he issued a memo not about that but
rather directing the fbi
to protect school boards from imaginary
threats
the memo says and i'll read it it says
in recent months there's been a
disturbing spike in harassment
intimidation and threats of violence
against school board administrators
board members teachers and and staff who
participate in the vital work of running
our nation's public schools while
spirited debate about policy matters is
protected under our constitution that
protection does not extend to threats of
violence or efforts to intimidate
individuals based on their views threats
against public servants are not only
illegal they run counter to our nation's
core values those who dedicate their
time and energy to ensuring that our
children receive a proper education in a
safe environment deserve to be able to
do their work without fear for their
safety the department takes these
incidents seriously and is committed to
using its authority and resources to
discourage these threats identify them
when they occur and prosecute them when
appropriate in the coming days the
department will announce a series of
measures designed to address the rise in
criminal conduct directed towards school
personnel coordination and partnership
with local law enforcement is critical
to implementing these measures for the
benefit of our nation's nearly 14 000
public school districts to this end i'm
directing the fbi working with each
united states attorney to convene
meetings with federal state local and
territorial leaders in each federal
judicial district within 30 days of this
issuance of the memo these meetings will
facilitate the discussion of strategies
for addressing threats against school
board administrators board members
teachers and will open dedicated lines
of communication for threat reporting
assessment and response
now
just to be perfectly clear
there has been
no violence against school board members
at all
the very small number of violent
incidents at meetings have been brief
scuffles between protesters where nobody
got hurt and that's on both sides okay
people on both sides of an issue show up
uh the conversation gets a little bit
heated and uh and then there's a scuffle
and no one really gets hurt
as for threats and intimidation which is
the main thing he's focusing on
i've been at some of these meetings
where threats and intimidation allegedly
happened i mean i've been at the
meetings where the media reports ah
there's threats and intimidation
i've also watched videos of other
meetings where it supposedly occurred
and i have heard very little of anything
that could be accurately described that
way
mostly i've heard angry parents
expressing their point of view sometimes
raising their voice
god forbid but that's as far as it goes
and yet we're supposed to believe that
parents getting a little heated during a
school board meeting is some kind of
national security threat that requires a
federal law enforcement response
the fbi has done nothing at all in
response to blm and t for rioters who
openly harass and intimidate law
enforcement and civilians
often do much worse than that but now
they mobilize against parents at school
boards
as someone who's been accused of being
you know one of the ringleaders of this
school board movement i expect i'll
probably be on the fbi most wanted list
by the end of the week
and it's clear what this is really about
the fbi doesn't care about the
harassment of public officials not
generally anyway if they did the feds
would be tracking down cinema's
harassers and shipping their butts back
to mexico
i mean they are illegal aliens as they
confessed
no for all their talk about intimidation
this itself what the fbi do is doing is
an intimidation tactic
this is about intimidating parents
regular working-class people
who've had the gall the nerve to speak
up against the system's indoctrination
and abuse of their children the public
school system is the factory it's the
assembly line where kids are shuffled
along and they're assembled and packaged
in the way the state wants in order to
make them ideologically compliant
vassals
but this grassroots non-violent uprising
of parents and school boards has
threatened that system and exposed it
and the powers that be cannot allow it
what this means first of all is that the
law is dead in this country that's not
hyperbole it's dead and it's been the
case for quite some time
when federal law enforcement is
mobilized against middle class parents
who are upset at their school board
members
that's a sign one of the more glaring
signs but certainly not the only one but
there's no higher law in this country
beyond the whims and desires of the
elites the law is
don't upset or interfere with them
that's the only law
they recognize no other
but it also means on the positive side
that our work in these school board
meetings is having an effect
uh it's making a difference
which means now is the time to double
down not back down
that means keep showing up keep speaking
out
and i can tell you that's exactly what
i'll be doing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated